make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so as promised in a previous video
actually yesterday's video
or the day before yesterday the video
that we did about dark nights metal and
the multiverse and all that i promised
you guys that i would make a video about
the overvoid the over monitor
all that kind of stuff something to
understand going into this though
is that all of this is largely
speculation when grant morrison
created the overvoid he didn't really
hold our hand and walk us through it and
say
this is the nature of the thing that's
the reason why you see so many people
out there who
more or less speculate on what the
overvoid is but i think this is going to
give us a pretty solid understanding
going forward until such a time
as somebody like grant morrison comes
along and basically offers some
explanation to this it's one of the
biggest issues that dc struggled with
over the course of their entire
publication history
is effectively organizing and
consolidating their greater cosmology
right it's just kind of a thing that's
there and sometimes somebody references
it so the overvoid
at its core represents effectively
imagination and that's why
it's described as kind of like this
infinite white sheet of paper more or
less and that on this singular you know
this giant white sheet of paper there's
a singular tiny spot that represents
like
everything in dc comics and the grand
scheme of the imagination of what we can
all achieve
dc comics is virtually nothing let's
kind of take this back right because
this is easier to understand if we look
at it in the in
in terms of levels right from like a
singular universe running up to a
multiverse to the omniverse to the
overvoid taking things back
way way way back all the way to like
action comics number one we had the
introduction of superman following
superman we had a whole huge explosion
of superheroes in terms of like hawkman
and like the spectre and batman and so
on and so forth and the way this worked
is that you had
all these different superheroes
operating in what eventually became
known
as earth 1. and we knew that it was
earth 1 for a couple different reasons
the first reason comes in the form of
batman and superman crossing over for
the first time and that basically
solidified that all the superheroes that
we saw
dc publishing at that point in time
existed on the same earth
up until that point it was like the
difference between like daredevil
on netflix and the marvel cinematic
universe movies right they may or may
not exist in the same place were never
really given a definitive answer but
when superman and batman crossed over
it was dc saying batman's in gotham
superman's a metropolis and each one can
travel to the other's location
they both exist on the same world now
the the actual indication of this having
a numerical designation which is to say
the idea of dc
calling this earth one didn't come along
until we got flash of two worlds right
the flash of two earth storyline
and that was basically when dc created
the multiverse and this was important
because superheroes started dropping off
in popularity in the mid 1940s and then
in the early 1950s julia schwartz asked
the question
what would happen if we took the origin
of a superhero and we tied it to science
fiction and then we gave this kind kind
of science fiction based superhero and
that was the introduction of barry allen
the flash a guy who was doused by
chemicals struck by lightning and became
the flash uh he took the place of of jay
garrick as the flash who had been
cancelled some number of years prior
the problem with this is that dc did not
explain where jay garrick went he was
simply just
cancelled one day and you never got an
answer right so for those of you guys
coming from marvel comics it would be
like if carol danvers simply just
disappeared one day and then you got a
new captain marvel in her set right he
was
never given an answer to where carol
danvers went the result of this is that
in order for dc
to satisfy fan interest and to also
provide some measure of continuity in
terms of why things have changed and
offering an explanation to it the flash
of two-world story was introduced as a
way of saying all the superheroes that
we saw
operating during the time that dc was
publishing comics in world war
ii they all came from a universe called
earth 2. all the superheroes that you
saw
basically operating at that point in
time in the 1950s was earth 1.
to make this simpler time you saw comics
published at the time when jay garrick
was a superhero that was all earth 2.
and when barry allen became the flash
everything after that was all earth 1.
following that dc created like this
great huge multiverse you got earth 3
which was
the crime syndicate of america where
basically all the traditional
superheroes were actually super villains
different things along those lines but
the long and short of this is that dc's
multiverse became
wildly chaotic and it was very very
difficult to keep up with what was
happening or to even get
into comics at that point in time if you
were somebody new who had never read
comics before and so in order to fix all
of this
dc launched the crisis on invented earth
event which basically
wiped out the entirety of the multiverse
and in its place what you got was simply
new earth there was no multiverse
anymore there was just one singular
universe
and that was basically it new origins
were given that basically fell in line
with the idea that there was only ever
one universe there were a few outliers a
couple characters whose origins didn't
really make sense
and that's why you got future crisis
events right zero hour crisis in time
infinite crisis final crisis trying to
reconcile all that stuff right to
basically correct the errors that came
after the events of crisis on
infinitives but with the idea of there
simply being a new earth you've got
stuff like hypertime that's not really
important for this discussion but
infinite crisis basically saw the
multiverse coming back and it wasn't
until the events of final crisis that
the superheroes became aware of the fact
that the multiverse had returned but
ever since the events of infinite crisis
the multiverse has been back right it's
basically been there as a mainstay in dc
comics now the reason why this matters
and the reason why i offered you that
explanation is one so you can have a
better understanding of what's going on
in terms of dark knight's metal and like
the idea of the original crisis event
versus infinite crisis versus final
crisis and kind of understand how all
those two all those things tie together
but the other reason why i told you this
is because
thinking of the overvoid insofar as
going from like a hierarchy of a
universe to the omniverse it basically
goes like this
so what you have is you have a singular
universe and inside the singular
universe in dc comics you have the green
lantern corps and you have batman and
you have superman and wonder woman and
all that kind of stuff right we can use
earth 0 or earth prime as it's called
ndc comics which is what the numerical
designation
for the main dc universe is after the
events of new 52 we can call that a
singular universe right now beyond that
you have
basically an infinite number of
universes dc only focuses on 52
because for whatever reason dc loves
that number right we don't really know
why
they just do they love the number 52
right so whenever you hear about dc
whenever you're reading a comic and it
says well there's only 52 universes that
we know of it's because only 52 have
been explored up to that point there's
an actual infinite number of universes
out there we just haven't really seen
any others besides those 52 but the idea
here is that beyond this singular
universe
we have a multiverse right a giant
combination of universes that exist out
there and for the most part the
multiverse is largely considered to be
infinite because there are
an infinite number of universes but
beyond that multiverse we then have
what's called
the omniverse and the omniverse is
basically a collection of multiverses
dc comics has its own multiverse and
then you might have like the twilight
zone and if we look at the tv show
twilight zone each story is largely
self-contained and you can even go as
far as to say
each story is actually its own universe
within the twilight zone you have their
multiverse and then if you go and you
look at marvel comics marvel comics has
their whole multiverse
all these different multiverses from
across every single method of publishing
right everything from books like moby
dick to
treasure island all the way up to like
tv shows like black mirror on netflix or
even things that have nothing to do with
comic books which is something like
alice in wonderland right all of these
have their own universes right they have
their own their own multiverses
and so the omniverse is a collection of
every single universe or multiverse that
exists out there because sometimes you
have things like alice in wonderland
which doesn't have a multiverse right
it's just a singular story told in a
linear way from beginning to end
and there's no alternate realities to
explore there right i mean i guess the
possibility exists like what would have
happened if alice didn't go down the
rabbit hole or what would have happened
if alice uh had like killed the red
queen
you know so like the queen of hearts
somewhere on the line or something crazy
but it doesn't really matter the whole
point of this
is that beyond this multiverse and
beyond this omniverse
you have the overvoid and that's why the
overvoid is described as this giant
white sheet of paper and the dc
multiverse is just the singular speck on
it because in the grand scheme of
imagination
in all possible creation the dc
multiverse is just this tiny itty-bitty
thing that there's a litany of other
things that are on here right everything
that we as human beings could possibly
create
is part of this overvoid and so that's
that's the important thing to understand
is that while the overvoid
basically represents the idea of what we
as human beings can make and the context
that it was given grant morrison
only focused on the multiverse now why
it was represented as a singular white
sheet and why it wasn't just simply a
whole bunch of squares that have like
everything that we've ever created just
kind of trailing on to the point where
it basically goes out of uh goes out of
panel i don't really know right i have
no real idea
another theory that comes with the
overvoid and the over monitor is that it
only is contained to dc comics right
it doesn't represent anything in
relation to anything outside of dc
comics now the reason why it's called
the overvoid and the reason why it is
just a giant white sheet of paper with
the dc multiverse just kind of existing
there is because
in relation to everything that's been
created in dc
versus everything that could be created
in dc comics the multiverse is virtually
nothing right because the imagination of
us as people is limitless and so you
have something like scott snyder's
batman run
which is virtually nothing compared to
all the things scott snyder could
imagine doing in dc
comics right jeff john's green lantern
run is nothing in comparison to all the
things jeff johns
could possibly do across all of dc
comics that everything outside of that
singular
multiversal spec on the overvoid is
basically everything
dc hasn't done yet right that's
essentially what it is right so again
it's kind of grant morrison
making an intangible concept tangible
right that's basically what it is right
that the overvoid represents what
dc could imagine doing over the course
of their entire publication history
every story they could make in the
future
and then that little tiny speck being
everything that they've done so far
right so it's kind of a crazy thing it's
a little bit wild a little bit bonkers
but again that's kind of what you run
into when you're when you're talking
about grant morrison right that's why
you kind of have a lot of fans who are
split on him you know you have like
super
hardcore grant morrison fans who are
like you simply don't understand them
even though they're largely saying that
not understanding him or you have people
like me who look at grant morrison and
just say you make things more
complicated than they need to be
just tell the story and let's call it a
day right that's kind of
that's kind of my thing you know when i
read comics sometimes i like to think
sometimes i don't and there are times
when i really enjoy reading comics where
i'm basically just kind of scrolling
through the pages and not giving any
real thought to what's happening
enjoying the madness unfolding right
like i just i kind of enjoy that
sometimes so hopefully this cleared
things up for you guys uh hopefully it
basically made sense of what the over
monitor or overvoid is
it's just total imagination in dc comics
right all the white space there
is everything that dc has not done yet
and it represents the potential of what
they could do
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you